what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
hello I'm Kristian harloff now he might
be wearing a marble shirt but between
the two of us Kristian harloff is the
only one who's seen do you Patrol
I have HBO max I'm planning on watching
do Patrol and I've even had the DC
Universe average haven't got around to
it he's seen all Doom Patrol people have
been asking me to check his trailer out
but I'm like I haven't seen the show
he's here today and I was like yeah man
let's check it out Aaron's gonna lead
the discussion and maybe this'll finally
convinced me to go watch the show so
Aaron get ready to inform me and
slightly spoil me
[Music]
let's eat this yeah there's a lot of
explaining
[Music]
well I got to start this chef dude it's
great
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell
Wow whoa okay I gotta start this show
what are your thoughts there oh man that
was really cool it definitely doesn't
hurt no this is definitely very much in
tune with the first season still really
weird still very eccentric seems like
it's gonna be very character focused I
think the show really strikes a good
balance of being off the walls insane
while having really relatable sort of
damaged characters okay and it's it kind
of walks that line and I think in
addition to Harley Quinn this show and
hardly point are the two strongest
things that the DC Universe has going
right now I'll even say that my favorite
character in the show which is he's
typically seen as more of a superhero in
the Doom Patrol isn't necessarily
superhero team and Lisa in this
interpretation Cyclops
not Cyclops what am I saying cyborg
there we go cyborg is probably the most
interesting person on the show because
he's taken a superhero mold brought into
this weird eccentric world of outcasts
and misfits and yeah man the rest of
them are really people trying to figure
out what to do with their lives are all
really old and they explain why they're
old in the show I don't want to spoil
too much room no how about this you go
into detail about what you thought of
this trailer and I would just keep my
ears shut and you just do your thing
error okay
so the season 2 trailer showed a lot of
stuff that sort of left off in the first
season how at the end of the first
season
most of the Doom Patrol became small
because of the events of the finale with
mr. nobody and then they kind of expand
upon that and I've had the pleasure of
seeing some of the episodes of season 2
just a few of them and I feel like they
definitely dive further into what
gonna happen and them getting bigger
again and just like the stuff with
Dorothy which is the Chiefs caveman
daughter which is really kind of
interesting and seeing where they go
with that I'm really excited about the
trajectory and the wackiness this show
has to offer especially with Jane and
the Underground and her 62 or 64
personalities and robot-man kind of
getting over his issues of being a dick
all the time but yeah then I think it's
gonna be cool especially with the sex
men what the hell is that I don't know
and I think he's gonna be a real tree
either Dan in the street when that kind
of comes to fruition when he gets the
chance to see it you gotta have a good
time can I take my figures out you can
take your fingers out oh I take the pop
I heard the pop that better have been it
I know Wow
are you okay like I started to bleed I
see it little [ __ ] well thanks for doing
that Erin DuPage I was gonna great
you're gonna enjoy it I mean it looks
awesome I'm gonna start it I have no
choice now while I'm playing all these
video games catching up on Clone Wars
not gonna start doing patrol content
overload is what my brain is now
alright guys will fall Eragon social
media subscriber the real rejects I'll
let you know when I'm catch too caught
up on Doom Patrol see you guys later see
you guys